we're back with another set of secrets
you probably don't know about
you might be wondering how the heck are
we still able to keep making these
and well i just gotta say breath of the
wild is just that good
if you enjoy a breath of the wild
content let us know by liking this video
as it takes a ton of work to put these
together for you
alright let's go did you know that
enemies can parry your attacks
they have a special animation for it and
you can even hear the parry's sound
effect
but it won't slow down the game like it
does for you
bonfires themselves are heavier than the
bundle of wood that it's made from
if you need to weigh a switch down throw
some wood down first then
light it on fire to increase its weight
boomerangs normally fall down if they
collide with any objects
with some exceptions including other
weapons which they will ricochet off
and sometimes even reverse directions
ancient weapons and arrows break crown's
blocks this also includes the blue flame
have you ever been in this situation
before you smack the stasis object too
many times and now you can't stop it
and you have to see it blast off into
the sunset well one master sword beam
stops it completely in its tracks and
resets
the launch for you dragons can run into
objects making bumping noises against
the environment
check out farage crashing into garuda
summit
normal and ancient arrows slowly float
back up to the water surface after being
shot underwater
but bomb arrows are extremely buoyant
and if shot during the rain they will
pop out from underneath the water
did you know that there's one weapon
that can go straight through walls
khorak leaf's gusts can go small
distance through walls and you can take
advantage of this in sneaking situations
to distract enemies through solid
objects
and even knock down enemies off of tall
platforms from below
did you know that the dlc falling
treasure chests aren't actually treasure
chest until they land
it's actually the same rocks that are
usually bouncing around inside of
shrines
[Music]
there are multiple ways to light your
way in the thai flow ruins besides
holding a torch
holding deruk's protection is decent but
using lightning rod balls
holding multiple star fragments in your
hands and activating your bosus fury as
a sort of sonar radar are good ways to
navigate the ruins as well
but a weapon smuggled torch and the
master cycle is the brightest mobile
setup that you can make
alright i've got multiple shield surf
traveling tricks for you
if you have a good slick shield but it's
heavily damaged shield surf then right
as you land switch to a less broken
shield
you keep the sliding properties of the
first shield but the durability of the
second shield you just switched to
most people know that snow and sand use
no shield surf durability but did you
know that every path consumes no
durability as well
even if the terrain doesn't look like it
every tan colored path
on the map consumes no durability
tiny bumps will ruin your day though you
can also simply keep switching shields
every few seconds while shield surfing
to use no durability
most people know that rock octorocks
like to spit out sucked up equipment
and even clean rusted weapons but did
you know that you can actually catch
these items
it's a little tough in real time so a
guaranteed way to do this is to hop into
bullet time
right as the equipment is thrown at you
then you can grab it mid-air
ganon's horse is special and has a
bigger attacking hitbox than a standard
horse
it even has the ability to reflect
octorok rocks right back
also you don't really give a second
thought to fighting rock or treasure
octorocks
you simply attack them while they're
above ground pretty simple but while
it's protected you can actually flush
them out by activating urbosa's fury
shooting a multi-shot shock bow at the
base of the item or using a shock trap
to flush the little guy out
water and mud conduct shock arrows but
did you know that lava does too
doesn't make much sense but alrighty
also you've seen weapons conduct
electricity before
probably hundreds if not thousands of
times but have you ever seen it move
lightning wand conductivity is special
and can be moved with the object
unlike normal conductivity with shock
weapons or arrows you can even stasis
launcher electric current towards your
enemies
[Applause]
a couple bokoblins in hyrule with large
burnable weapons can sometimes get stuck
in a hilarious loop
if they sleep close enough to the
campfire they will burn from the weapon
pick up the weapon then search for the
attacker then it will go back to sleep
and drop the weapon and burn itself
all over again basically my last brain
cell in a nutshell
did you know it's actually possible to
steal and even register an npc's horse
as your own
if any npc is dismounted keep bumping
the npc towards a mud pool
then use an amiibo chest to push the
horse into the mud
the drowned horse will respawn as a
rideable horse
[Music]
since the horse despawns if you go too
far away from its owner use the npc
hostage to go back to the stable and
register it as your own horse
[Music]
if this game had a karma system this
whole process was stink of bonus bad
karma points
if you're going for efficiency and not
too worried about your ego i've got a
couple enemy specific cheesing tips for
you that aren't just sneak strike chains
lisalfos are completely blind beneath
their chin so just coming from above and
as long as you don't knock them away
hit them as many times as you want
goblins can be cheesed with simply one
flame blade and a piece of wood
throw down a piece of wood at its feet
after it missed an attack then
do a spin attack with the flame blade
now go grab a snack it'll be dead a
minute later
[Music]
any lionel near a body of water which
are here here
and here on master mode can be cheesed
with a couple arrows and one strong
weapon
simply bait the lynel to the water then
head shot it build two cryoness blocks
in the front
then one in the back this is basically a
lionel jail so simply jump on its back
attack wait a second then jump on again
back attacks use no durability so you're
free to loop this until the lynel's dead
poor guy doesn't even know what's going
[Music]
on
the wolf link amiibo has an extremely
rare attack animation
if there are multiple targets he'll
sometimes do his signature multi-dash
attack
straight from twilight princess
moldu kings are specifically weak to
electric attacks because of their iron
skin they'll do critical strikes every
time
and do more damage than bomb arrows or
ancient weapons will ever do
igneous and frost taluses can be stunned
by hitting them with the opposite
element
and they'll eventually recharge their
body parts with their own element again
but you can actually strike them with
their own element to recharge it
immediately
letting you stun them over and over
again whenever you want
you can foot stool off of a choo choo
with a shield and get some bullet time
the hottest location in breath of the
wild is obviously death mountain where
you literally catch on fire
it's so hot that the sheikah slate
errors out on how hot it is
so you'd think right next to the border
of death mountain is the highest
recorded
temperature at 102 degrees well that
trophy instead goes to the lowest point
of gerudo desert
at this encampment here which can reach
as high as 131 degrees
the coldest location is in hebrew and
you might think that it would be at the
very top of hebrew peak
while it is definitely cold up here the
coldest area is actually this area at
pikita stone grove
which at the highest area of pakita
stone grove reads at a whopping negative
82 degrees
ouch enemies with burning weapons can do
considerably more damage to you
but by watching a memory it can
instantly incinerate it out of their
hands
each piece of equipment on link has a
separate hitbox if you hold a burnable
object on your back and in front of you
right at the border of death mountain's
hot air only the equipment and bounds
will burn
this hitbox is so accurate to the pixel
that even link's breathing will affect
the equipment being in and out of
burning bounce
the attention to detail in this game is
pretty amazing
and that's it we are still discovering
new things consistently to this day
so this may be a series that never stops
if you enjoy breath of the wild content
be sure to check out our other videos
including expert reacts and breakdown
videos
and for everything else stay tuned right
here on gamespot
you